china has endorsed a sweeping overhaul
of hong kong's electoral system
seen by many as another nail in the
coffin for the pro-democracy movement
the reforms include increasing the
number of beijing-approved officials in
hong kong's legislature
china's aim ensuring only quote
patriotic figures
can run for positions of power
china's leaders voting in favor of
giving regular hong kong residents
less of a say members of beijing's
national people's congress standing
committee or the npcsc
voted unanimously in favor of the new
rules 167-0
they see the changes as necessary to
filter out
undesirable elements and to make sure
the right people
can stand for positions of power
this improvement of the electoral system
will prevent the anti-china
rabble-rousers
from being present in the election
committee or the legislative council
in order to engage in sabotage
subversion
or instigation that is how we can ensure
implementation of the patriots
administering
hong kong principle the new measures
also reduce the number of seats up for
selection by ordinary hong kongers for
their legislative council
previously voters picked 35 seats half
of the 70 seats in the legislature
that number is now reduced to 20. while
hong kong's pro-beijing government
welcomed the move saying it was a step
in the right direction
pro-democracy lawmakers lamented the
changes saying they represent a
regressive legislative rollback
the pro-democracy camp fears the voice
of hong kong's people would be
completely lost in the debate chambers
in the past we know that the major
problems that we are facing
it's not just about housing or not just
about
whether or not the young people can get
the social mobility
it is about whether the system can
actually reflect
what hong kong people think on the
streets of the special administrative
region
many hong kongers expressed concern
i always think about how it was promised
that hong kong wouldn't change for 50
years
but it hasn't even been 25 and i think
it's already changed a lot
that's why i'm worried about my future
as well as those people around me
hong kong has already changed what
election are you kidding
me this isn't an election it's merely a
game that benefits certain people
it's meaningless
with the system overhaul that skepticism
could soon be shared by many voters
making the first legislative elections
under the new system in december
all the more interesting and for more on
this let's bring in dw correspondent
phoebe kong who joins us now from
hong kong so phoebe tell us more about
these reforms
this reform has effectively reset almost
all electoral rules
in hong kong this is the most aggressive
political
overhaul we've seen since a hong kong's
handover
that on one hand beijing tries to dilute
the opposition representation by
drastically reducing the directly
elected seats
in the legislature and the election
committee which is responsible for
picking the chief executive
then replacing those vacancies with
people from
government appointed organizations and
beijing controlled
sectors so as a result for example the
uh
seats in the legislature used to account
for
the directly elected seats used to
account for half of the legislature in
the past
but under the new rules in the future
only less than a quarter
and on the other hand no matter who wins
this election and
whoever wants to run for it must first
go through
a loyalty test just by the authorities
so on the new vetting mechanism will be
controlled by the government alone
and senior officials will be the veteran
members who approve
the candidacy and they will take advice
from chief executive and beijing
officials
and it's also the very first time in
hong hong's history that the national
security police
will actually have a say to decide which
candidates
to be disqualified or not now we've seen
beijing you know try to reign in the
pro-democracy movement in several
ways in recent times is this really the
nail in the coffin for democracy in hong
kong
well the authorities they today they say
they argued
that the new uh institution will
represent
a more diverse interest of the society
because its
size and composition above increase but
in fact when we look at the numbers of
the
directly elected seats they are actually
which are
directly elected by the general public
by the general voters in hong kong these
seats
are drastically diminished and not to
mention the multiple hurdles added under
the new proposal
that um that is it's getting even more
difficult for people to run for election
because they have to prove their loyalty
and allegiance to beijing
at first hand and beijing is really
trying every means to ensure
there is zero risk in any election and
we can expect that the election results
will be more controllable than before
that in the future elections but um the
people's will and people's
the the public opinion will be
suppressed and
uh even more underrepresented in the
future elections
speaking of public opinion i mean what
has been of the reaction to this
sweeping overhaul
well at the general public um i i can
see a mood
that um people are very concerned
because uh like um
this is a huge con a huge conservancy as
i have mentioned that this is the most
aggressive uh
overhaul a huge political blow since the
national security law this is
um this is another major change
fundamental change in hong kong's
politics
but um this reform has been realized
just within a month within extensive
consultation
at local level and the critics and also
of course the
opposition can see this as an end of
their political career within political
institutions because they think beijing
is determined to stop all of them from
entering the political institution
through elections and elections used to
be one of the few remaining peaceful and
legitimate ways
for them to continue efficacy but now
many of them
protests have been largely banned and
now election seems
another dead end for them to continue
that movement and it will be even harder
for the opposition camp to continue
the advocacy peacefully and safely in
the future
dw correspondent phoebe kong in hong
kong thank you very much for that update